ce dernier trimestre 2013 est marqué par
des mouvements de protestation début
octobre le maire deslancour Jean-Michel
Fourgous lance une pétition contre la
semaine scolaire des 4 jours et demi il
estime cette réforme trop coûteuse en
quelques jours il compte 15000
signatures à poissi 7ette salariés en
grève de la fin depuis le 18 septembre
reçoivent la visite d'Olivier
beszancenau l'ancien leader
charismatique de NPA ces salariés
dénoncent leurs condition de travail la
grève se terminera le 30 octobre
quelques jours plus tard la nouvelle
tombe pour les salariés de Rama à
Montini le magasin fermera ses portes le
20 septembre il était devenu l'emblème
des premières luttes pour l'ouverture le
dimanche mais l'enseigne n'aura pas
résisté à la concurrence des commerces
voisins qui ont l'autorisation
dominicale les 23 salariés seront
reclassés autre mouvement celui des
sage-femme lancé le 16 octobre elles
souhaitent que leur profession soit
mieux reconnu selon elle leur métier est
équivalent à celui d'un gynécologue ou
d'un obstétricien mais les coûts de
consultation sont beaucoup moins élevés
les agriculteurs franciliens mobilisés
en ce 21 novembre pour demander la
démission de leur ministre Stéphane LEF
et dénoncer des hausses de charges
sociales en Île-deFrance se points de
blocage dont TR rien que pour les
ivelines sur la nationale 10 et la
nationale 12 l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin en proie des difficultés
financières un déficit de 4 millions
d'euros à combler par un plan de
réduction des dépenses personnel
enseignants et étudiants réunis en
intersyndical manifeste devant le
rectorat pour dire non au budget
d'austérité et au gel des emplois 10000
personnes selon la police 300 selon les
les organisateurs il y avait du monde
dans les rues de Versailles à l'appel du
Collectif la manif pour tous une
manifestation pour critiquer la
politique gouvernementale en matière
familiale un mouvement qui pourrait se
faire entendre aux prochaines élections
municipales il aura fallu plus de 3 ans
pour voir l'école Victor Hugo des
clésousbou accueillir à nouveau des
élèves il ne reste plus aucune trace de
l'incendie qu'il avait détruite en avril
2010 des travaux qui ont duré plus
longtemps que prévu mais l'établissement
a remporté un plébiscite samedi 16
novembre est officiel iement inauguré
l'église Saint-Pierre de plaisir la fin
d'un chantier démarré il y a 19 mois un
chantier financé en grande partie par la
mairie avec l'appuie de 313 donateurs un
chantier qui se termine un autre kit
démarre à la rentrée 2015 à Montini le
Bretonneux devrait s'ouvrir l'estaka une
école d'ingénieur spécialisée dans le
domaine des
transports une page économique en cette
fin d'année le campus du Crédit Agricole
est en chantier le groupe souhaite
donner une autre envergure à ce site de
Guille en cour et accueillir d'ici 2016
de nouveaux collaborateurs à terme plus
de 1200 des sourires aussi du côté des
clés sous-bois le 4 décembre W nation
Paris le plus grand complexe franç de
magasin d'usine de luxe a ouvert ses
portes et tandis que W nation organise
son ouverture les mines sont grises du
côté de Montini carré privé West c'est
déjà terminé le projet de marque de luxe
à pré cassé est abandonné il devait
relancer Sky West le centre commercial
se cherche un nouvel avenir et puis
autre visage fermé cette fois du côté du
centre commercial des gaâtines à plaisir
le centre est touché par un incendie CIN
commerces ravagés par les flammes le
sinistre s'élève à plusieurs centaines
de milliers d'euros et on termine cette
rétro avec deux bonnes nouvelles Déclic
Théâtre à 20 ans et pour l'occasion la
compagnie de théâtre d'impro basé à
trappe a proposé son fiestacle parmi les
invités deux anciens qui ont fait leur
chemin Arnaud saère et Isa dumbia et le
monde du cyclisme l'attendait le
vélodrome de 50 ans en Yveline est
présenté officiellement à la presse le
19 décembre l'équipe de France sur piste
a pu effectuer ses premiers tours de
roues pour les champions de BMX mais le
vélodrome de Saint-Quentin Enel ne se
résume pas aux pistes ce clerfontaine du
cyclisme français permettra à la
Fédération de perfectionner son pôle de
haut niveau et surtout de préparer
l'avenir et les prochains jeux
olympiques inauguration officielle le 30
janvier
prochain